-Making her TV debut, performing
her hit song, "Hrs and Hrs"
from her EP, "Public Displays
of Affection,"
give it up for Muni Long!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ Can I sing to you? ♪
♪ Oooh ♪
♪ Ooh, can I, ooh, can I,
ooh, can I ♪
♪ Si-i-i-i-ng ♪
[ Harmonizing ]
♪♪
-♪ Oh, ooh ♪
-♪ Oh, yeah ♪
-♪ Who loves you ♪
♪ Ooh ♪
-I don't usually do this,
but...
can I sing to you?
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Yours, mine, ours ♪
♪ I could do this for hours ♪
♪ Sit and talk to you
for hours ♪
♪ I wanna give you
your flowers ♪
♪ And some champagne chalice ♪
♪ Order shrimp
and lobster towers ♪
♪ But it's me
that gets devoured ♪
♪ Ooh, when you do what you do,
I'm empowered ♪
♪ You give me a superpower ♪
♪ Together,
the world could be ours ♪
♪ You sit me on the counter ♪
♪ Instantly,
it's thunder showers ♪
♪ Stormin' for a couple hours ♪
♪ When we finish,
take a shower ♪
♪ I could do this for hours ♪
♪ And hours and hours ♪
♪ And hours, hours ♪
♪ Usually don't like nobody ♪
♪ And when I say nobody,
I mean nobody ♪
♪ Everybody's full of it ♪
♪ You're just a homie
once they hit ♪
♪ Felt like givin' up on love ♪
♪ They almost made me quit ♪
♪ Then I met you ♪
♪ When I met you,
I knew this was it ♪
♪ I've never been in love
like this ♪
♪ A love like ours ♪
♪ I pray for it on my knees ♪
♪ Every night for some hours ♪
♪ And hours and hours ♪
♪ And hours and hours
and hours ♪
♪ I could do this for hours ♪
♪ And hours and hours ♪
♪ What's yours is mine
and ours ♪
♪ And yours, mine, and ours ♪
♪ Oh, I could sit and talk to
you for hours ♪
♪ Sit and look at you
for hours ♪
♪ Makin' love to you for hours ♪
♪ Layin' on your chest
for hours ♪
♪ Tellin' you jokes for hours ♪
♪ Holdin' you close for hours ♪
♪ And hours and hours ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪ Whoa, whoa, I, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah ♪
♪ Hours and hours ♪
♪ Oh, oh ♪
♪ Oh ♪
♪ Hours and hours ♪
♪♪
♪ Oh ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]